no to constitutional change and no to
Prime Minister Matteo Renzi that's the
frosty message sent to Rome from the
central square in Reggio Emilia in the
north of Italy lawmaker Manlio de
Stefano is on the campaign trail for his
five star movement Italy's biggest
political opposition group for him the
referendum is just a warm-up act paving
the way for new elections make a cross
for Liberty across to say go to hell -
the political cast that has failed us
for so long
DeStefano isn't only referring to each
Hallion politicians but also to what he
calls a European elite the 35 year old
is a convinced euro skeptic who wants
Italy to ditch the euro as soon as
possible
European people are getting very tired
of the fact that everything that is
going on is just based on the financial
and banking institutions if you think
about the European Parliament the 90% of
what they do is just to save banks and
find a way to make money go around the
Europe this is the sort of message his
followers want to hear after years of
economic stagnation and high debt many
Italians are looking for someone to
blame
Robert on Europe should become less
technocratic Europe looks after its
banks instead of its citizens today
popery back on the campaign trail
DeStefano explains his movements doesn't
think that the EU itself is the problem
but that it needs change for instance he
wants the sanctions against Russia to be
dropped and hopes to get a better
migration deal for Italy if you don't
change the the
the grid of this European Union it will
fail it's written in the stars I mean
it's it's clear this man would even go a
step further
he's Matteo salvini the head of the
right-wing northern league as he puts it
he is fishing for no votes on this local
market in Milan like DiStefano
he's the euro skeptic hardliner populist
with a strong pro-russian leaning he
also wants out of the euro and doesn't
rule out leaving the block altogether
brexit [ __ ] in or exit trump in our
Novak's and when Hoffa wins the
presidential elections in Austria for
tough slaps in the face of the
establishment will be four victories for
the people Paulo a student and supporter
of the yes campaign still finds it hard
to believe that the center-left
government could come under such
pressure from populist movements both
left and right salvini and Grillo both
are the face of the same metal a face of
people that didn't try don't try to
change things through information and
through will but only through emotions
and scaring people in Italy rebellion is
in the air and anti-establishment
parties are hoping that the wind of
change blowing from the UK and the US
will help lift their campaign